you fool I think the problem was like
making sure doesn't taste like [ __ ] when
it's going down because like the castle
can you just mix it with sugar and then
you got other problems I know it's crazy
what do you think about stevia like so
the stevia there's it's it's a
non-nutritive sweeteners so it's not
like it's not like aspartame or
saccharine or what's the other ones
sucralose yeah which by the way those
have all been shown to like screw up the
microbiome yeah those are really bad
yeah they like change food by the way
coke is what the president drinks 12
cans a day of what yes
no wonder why's making [ __ ] decisions
twelve are you serious yeah so New York
Times story
they said that he drinks 12 cans of diet
coke a day and watches as much as eight
hours of television a day so he's he's
literally like a test monkey that really
true that's crazy it's really true see
if you can find that article 12 cans of
dare it is Trump reportedly drinks 12
cans of Diet Coke it looks like you're
you losing and using an ad blocker
what's the main the main sweetener in
Diet Coke aspartame is it aspartame yeah
Trump drinks dot twelve diet cokes per
day what can that do to a person's body
and then they have a scientist on we're
[ __ ] I'll tell you what it does to the
microbiome it like changes the
composition so that you're like you're
getting the kind of bacteria that are
really good at harvesting the glucose
from from like the small intestine area
and it makes people like become obese
like that's the associative studies and
people like that they've shown that in
people and then of course they've done
causal studies and animals showing that
but stevia is interesting because I've
seen positive studies with that where it
seems to like improve insulin
sensitivity which is kind of weird I
I personally am always I'll use stevia
like if I'm like gonna let's make some
hot cocoa with a hundred percent cocoa
and I just tastes like ass I'm like I
need some it's like otherwise you're
just doing a shot of it like
hot cocoa with no sugar yeah 100% cocoa
where's miss yeah cacao there's all
sorts of benefits with that too but but
yeah with this I don't really use a lot
of stevia like my in-laws they they like
to put it in their smoothies because
I've gotten so used to my smoothies
tasting Kaylee that I guess you know and
and plus I don't eat any anything sweet
so I don't really need it but they like
to put it in their smoothies and right
you know I don't I don't know if it has
any we haven't really seen negative
health consequences with the exception I
think there was one study in rats where
they gave him like exceptional amounts
and it like changed the hormonal profile
or something so I didn't consume any
during pregnancy because I was worried
about that but well don't be a rat study
study but I think that's probably my
choice if I were to sweeten something
like my put in my coffee or something I
put stevia Trump is grossly overweight
yeah that's so the microbiome what's
funny is that people taking diet coke
are trying are trying to like improve
they don't they don't you know they
don't want the refined sugar they don't
want to have the the constant insulin
response and so they're drinking the
diet coke it's kind of ironic that it's
like it's like making the more be obese
by changing the gut microbiome no is is
it safe to drink just one can every now
and again or is just something sure one
can every now and then it's okay you
know it's not I mean it's not going to
like completely not 12 cans a day or
even one kanaday you're constantly
uncertain your microbiome you're
constantly going to keep shifting it and
towards you know really one can a day
probably yeah because it's their
microbiome is yeah yeah the way taste
though diet coke doing joy a diet coke I
haven't had diet coke was like 2006 I
had one yesterday in the hotel cracked
it open really haven't I really haven't
had one since 2006 cold yeah I used to
drink I'm I used to drink them when for
light in college and stuff to stay awake
and study for exams and all that but if
you're taking something like that should
you take a corresponding like some sort
of a probiotic to try to combat that
I mean the problem with that is you know
the probiotics which by the way there's
all sorts of interesting studies that
have shown effectiveness of certain
probiotics that are you know have a lot
of that have live bacteria and a lot of
them but you know in order for the
probiotics to work you either have to
constantly take them or there needs to
be space in your gut for them to take
residence in right so if you're like
filling your body with all sorts of
sugar or diet coke and all this then
where where's the probiotic that you're
taking in gonna attach right so it's
kind of flow through and the flow
through has benefits but you have to
keep taking it you know for that for
that to happen so the so really a
healthy diets the way it's not you can't
just counteract with supplementation
healthy healthy diets the way meaning
you know the the fermentable fiber which
is what helps grow helps the the
commensal and good bacteria basically
grow and thrive but probiotics helped me
a lot like after I had some I had some
gut issues from from stress with
graduates graduate school and so that
definitely helped me and I don't I I
take him once in a while now like you
know but I don't I don't take them every
day like I did you know when I was like
trying to like heal myself and and the
one I was taking I think we've talked
about was 450 billion it's called VSL
number three but now there's another
company called vis biome that it's like
the guy who made this BSL number three
is doing this visible make the same
formulation I've tried it out as well
but it's like a little cheaper and I
don't have any affiliation with either
of those companies but there's been
clinical clinical studies with both of
them showing effectiveness and so it's
it's certainly an interesting field
growing field and there happens in the
clinical studies in humans were for
example the one that's super interesting
the brain the brain stuff the way it's
affecting the brain is interesting and
there's clinical studies there was one
recent one I think I tweeted where there
was like 10 randomized control trials
they weren't really high quality but
it's a start and it like improved
measures of anxiety and people other
studies have shown and Amaya's control
trial has been a couple others showing
it improves depression scores and also
in cognition so there's you know again
the immune system modulation of the
immune system will affect the brain mewn
system
definitely is connect you know basically
inflammatory factors and things like
that can cross over to the blood-brain
barrier and get in the brain and disrupt
neurotransmitter production and all
sorts of stuff but also the gut brain
access the bagel nerve we're like you
can make certain things that are like if
you if you have certain type act Irian
the gut that are making for example gaba
that can like stimulate the nerve in an
inhibitory way that like calms and it
does something calming to the so that it
to the brain part we don't really
understand all the mechanisms it's just
fascinating field that I'm like trying
to follow and keep up on you know but I
mean the question is to do normal
healthy people need to take probiotics
all the time and I don't know the answer
but I do think that we need to eat the
right foods to to get our microbiome
healthy and avoid things like you know
what's it called aspartame yeah
aspartame nutrasweet all that's the same
stuff right that's nutrasweet disaster
yeah i think it is the blue packet yeah
yeah